ich habe mich im letzten jahr mit nichts
anderem als essen beschäftigt und ich
wohne in köln dementsprechend gibt es
heute meine top 5 fuß hotspots ich habe
mich den kopf zerbrochen um euch das
beste zu präsentieren und ich freue mich
zuerst auf ein angenehmes frühstück mit
den besten kaffee in köln und einem
perfekten cheesecake das geht so leute
wie starten wir diesen leckeren tag
natürlich mit einem café und was zum
frühstücken und ihr wisst vielleicht ich
bin ein bisschen cafés noch so ich habe
zwei siebträgermaschinen legt sehr viel
wert auf guten kaffee und
dementsprechend ist das kann ich guten
gewissens sagen der beste spot für café
in köln wir starten beide coffee gang
und was genau so gut ist ist der
cheesecake deshalb lasst uns reingehen
[Musik]
also wirklich besser cup in köln motto
kunst allein die latte an so fein und
das ist durch zum mikrofon sein vater
und normal lecker und dazu wirklich ich
bin auch gespannt wenn du das gleiche
essen börsting
dieser schießt
du bist doch dann ganz warm und klebt so
zusammen kann ich schwören das ist der
beste cheesecake wenig gegessen haben
egal wo egal ob new york egal ob selbst
gemacht egal in welchem café pflaster
besser
gewusst dass man das gefühl ich kann das
einschneidende adresse so unfassbar
cremig der kaffee so unfassbar gut wenn
die so in den tag gestartet ist machst
du schon alles reden auto
so freunde das war schon mal ein guter
start jetzt müssen wir aber zum alten
bekannten manche von euch kennen denn
vielleicht geht jetzt nach ehrenfeld zu
wickie und wir essen exotisch denn es
geht afro soulfood direkt als zweites
heute was ich auch noch mal sagen wollte
mir war relativ wichtig dass ich nicht
so krasse hype sports frei nehmen denn
ich werde euch meine persönlichen
fabolous zeigen und irgendwie so krasse
instagram länder so deshalb gibt es bis
auf 1 heute wirklich nur geheimtipps und
deshalb wir uns nicht wirklich dran zu
bleiben jetzt kommt also leute zweiter
stopp
soulfood und so gut ist ihr programm
ricky den inhaber werden wir auch gleich
treppen und ich sage euch so viel er ist
eine legende und das essen ist
mindestens genauso legendär das
exotischste was heute auf der liste
stehen haben aber wir schauen jetzt erst
mal rein ich muss mit let's go aufgaben
sorry dass ich die ganze zeit lässt gott
sage
[Musik]
weißt du was wirklich stehe heute ein
video die besten fussball in köln fünf
restaurants habe ich mir ausgesucht
gewiss natürlich mit dabei ist normal
großen sack hier ist eine restaurant wo
jetzt wie sein sagt weißen haus und ich
habe gesagt lasst gibt es auch durch nur
hier
apostrophiert sie hat nach wien kommen
sie erst
einmal aufpreis mit schicken dann
stellen wir gar nicht weiter
[Musik]
doch weiß man sieht schon allein der
kreis für sich als unfassbar gewürzt und
einfach was besonderes aber hier oben
drauf ist die echte magie dieses du
dieses tomaten gut schmeckt zu unendlich
geschmackvoll dann haben wir oben drauf
schicken hieß es auf der haut knusprig
angebratenen das ist wirklich was für
menschen die schon viel gegessen haben
die gutes essen lieben und die bock auf
was neues haben wir das ist besonders
und hier für jeden der genug von stani
pommes hat gem preis aus yamswurzel ihr
wisst was händchen genauso wie ich nicht
mal was
genauso schmeckt es einfach etwas neues
was besonderes und ich sag das wird auch
euch steigt so muss man kaufen
er schmeckt es
schmeckt als wärst du irgendwie auch in
der welt unterwegs und würde es nicht
gerade in einer heimatstadt so schnell
und zehn minuten um die ecke fahren ist
einfach eine neue welt was leistet
gegessen habe ich habe auf jeden fall
noch ein bisschen platz weiter geht's
was mal was essen ein bisschen mehr noch
nächste station sushi und ich sage hier
einst leute das nehme ich nicht auf die
leichte schulter ich habe glaube ich
sehr viele sushi-restaurants ausgetestet
seitdem ich in köln band und das ist
wirklich mein lieblingsrestaurant was
ich besonders feierte sind kleiner laden
eigentlich ein kleiner geheimtipp sowas
ist ja sowieso ein bisschen mein ding
und wir sind jetzt hier zwei tische
draußen zwei tische drin und der
traumhafte flug ist auch schon da
die 24 ohne die ganz wichtig
[Musik]
punkt eins wie kann es sein dass keine
fast food kette auf der welt ihr
schicken so knusprig bekommt wie hier
wie kann es sein so ticken pops bisschen
sojasauce und
nummer zwei crunchy lachs rollen richtig
richtig christi frittiert ganz wichtig
ohne die bei mir das noch mal hört jungs
war drin
ich will mir
irgendwann ist glaube ich in den meisten
social spots zeigen aber auch sowas hier
der name sind offen richtig naki für
salz übertrieben wichtig was heute abend
wirklich habe viele so skisports
getestet in köln und hier stimmt einfach
alles von mir hier mal wirklich das ist
die absolute highlight rolle darin
stolzen preis aber ich sag euch wartet
mango rourke lachs und flambierte
mayonnaise oben drauf das ist durch mit
das krasseste was für mich in der sushi
welt gibt
eric muss jetzt auch mal probieren
übrigens rx face review als sich alle
schon mal gefragt wie eric auf sie kommt
diesem sonnentag nimmer hier so ein
stück so was so boudgoust
schön so ja dazu ich bin ernst gespannt
was du sagen willst weil das meine fable
sushi rolle
der blick ist so also noch krank oder
wieviele abgeht in deinen mund so eine
süße ich
noch nie gegessen und es ist so geil
digger wir haben es getestet ich glaube
es wird schon jetzt zeit für den
nächsten fuß fort was soll ich sagen
check auch für den zuschauer auf jeden
fall alle restaurants alle adressen sind
unten verlinkt und wir lassen uns jetzt
schmecken der märz hat ein bisschen
angefangen zu regnen und deshalb holen
wir uns jetzt die sonne in den magen und
wo geht das besser als mit einer
neuesten pizza mit der besten tipper in
köln ab zu nennen
einer meiner lieblingsplätze die werden
wir auch bestellen ist hier drüben die
areale mit tomaten geräucherten
kochschinken schafe honig pro die latte
und gebratenen champignons wenn ich das
sagen leute mit 100 wasser im mund
zusammen und wir wissen jetzt
[Musik]
was soll ich sagen dass dieser geruch
durch dieser scharfe rohe tomaten das
ist wirklich einfach nach andre hörmann
ich habe zum ersten mal hier nach
politischen pizza gegessen ich habe
häufig gemachter mann aber trotzdem ist
hier für mich der beste service der
boden musste ich verneigen und er ist
auch eine wahre italiener ist genau so
und jetzt
[Musik]
das muss man so es tut mir leid dieser
honig die man merkt es wird ja direkt da
drin gemacht für 90 sekunden 100
sekunden in den ofen allein die tomaten
sind so kranken band ist lustig bunten
schöne
marmorierung wenn ihr in köln seit eine
richtig gute bezeichnen wollte konnte
[Musik]
leute mir jetzt noch mal aufgefallen die
krasseste sache an dieser flitzer ist
der rand so bei normalerweise ist ein
rand knusprig oder flüssig aber dieser
rand hier ist knusprig und unfassbar für
fiktion also wie ist das besonders das
schafft lange nicht jede pizzeria und
deshalb müsst ihr das auch abchecken
wenn ihr in köln sein dass durch
schmecken weiß worauf jetzt wusste was
zu essen
ihr seht wo wir sind es ist kein
geheimtipp aber wäre eine frechheit ist
nicht mit einzunehmen die top fußball es
auch mit tom hier und leute kebab land
köln ehrenfeld steht einfach für sich
das gibt es in der form in der qualität
habe ich nur hier dieser kleine
container und da rauskommt so gutes
essen der klassiker donatella ist was
wir jetzt gestellt werden dann bin ich
ja auch sagt für heute leut ich sag's
euch ehrlich aber wir gehen jetzt rein
gesteckt
[Musik]
also leute ganz simpel aber teller zwei
spießl am gehacktes joghurts lose in
kleiner frischer salat und dann bulgur
und europa reist dazu unnormal lag
dieses geröstetem brot ich glaube es
gibt wenige sachen die ich nach so einem
tag noch essen könnte überhaupt aber das
ist eine davon das ist nicht so gut das
geht einfach immer
da sind von der roten soße und
knusprig sorgt in unfassbar wird sich
zum abnehmen zwischendurch wenn man aber
auch wieder so ein bisschen seine
palette ein bisschen neutralisierende
sehr einfach und endgegner dieses brot
schmeckt so rauch das wird direkt auf
dem see auf der holzkohle gemacht und
kann man hier noch sagen
jedes mal wieder und deshalb ist das
hier auch mit drin obwohl ist so bekannt
ist es ist einfach außer konkurrenz und
wer in köln ist muss sie essen punkt ist
so kann man nicht sagen
[Musik]
was für ein ende für diesen tag leute
unnormal lecker ich habe ein bisschen
bauchschmerzen hätten ich geh nach hause
ich sag mal so viel ich habe noch
mindestens genauso viele spots im panel
für ein zweites video wenn ihr das
irgendwann mal sehen wollt dann schreibt
in die kommentare aber jetzt erstmal
viel spaß beim ausprobieren wenn ihr in
köln seit mach's gut bis dahin
wirtschaft